how I got rich and got into the top 1%
was by studying the detail and the
similarties between the people that are
in the top 1% when I studied the way
rich people are the way they think the
way they behave their habits and then
just copied and emulated that that's how
I got rich as well I've been a
millionaire since the age of 25 I'm now
32 years old and I'm a multi-millionaire
this year alone I've bought two hotels
I've bought a factory a warehouse got
six pieces of land and over the last 12
months have generated over2 million in
Revenue across my businesses and I'm
going to be sharing how the top 1% stay
the top 1% in this video so you can do
the same thing too the first thing to
know is this top 1% sounds impressive
but it's not in fact I think that the
top 1% are mostly full of brokies and
let me explain why according to data and
you can Google this and find out
yourself but in the UK the top 1% means
you only need to be making £160,000 a
year now if you're making £160,000 a
year after tax you're going to be making
about 100 Grand a year that is not that
much money so I don't even think you
should aim to be in the top 1% I think
you should aim to be in the top 0.1% but
if you want to be in the top 0.1% the
first thing you need to do is you need
to never ever ever be a victim victim
mentality is something that not just
causes people to be broke but keeps
people broke if you're thinking oh man
it's not my fault oh this deal didn't
happen because this person never got
back to me oh it's because of my gender
my age my race my this my that I started
in business when I was 17 years old and
I did feel a little bit judged I'd walk
into a state agent people would be I
could tell people thinking who's this
kid yeah and I also wasn't educated I
flunked at of school age 16 and and I
didn't have any qualifications or
anything I'm not from a wealthy family
at all it was very easy for me to feel a
little bit like oh bit of a victim
things didn't go my way things didn't go
in my plan oh it's cuz I've not got a
car I can't get there oh it's because of
this oh it's because of that but one of
the things that my mentor taught me at
very young age Tony Tony crook is he
said to me there's people that have been
successful from your situation before
and if it's possible then you can do it
and just getting me out of that victim
mentality was the first thing that
helped me become successful so number
one is never ever be a victim number two
is the top 0.1% are always really good
at this one thing and that is sales they
know how to sells they know how to sell
their products sell their services they
can sell an idea you can't name me one
person who's a billionaire who's not
great at sales I'm not saying they're
extrovert you might be thinking when I
say sales like pushy manipulative
door-to-door salesman I'm not talking
about that I'm talking Steve Jobs type
of sales where he'd get you know create
a new product and do a presentation and
just have everybody W everybody eating
out of the palm of his hands at his
fingertips as he presents as he sells
his new products that's good sales even
Jesus was a good sales person you know
very direct you follow me you know
direct to the point he'd sell an idea
that's still around thousands of years
later Martin Luther King I Have a Dream
and everyone was gripped sold on the
idea of what he was sharing the vision
that he had that's good sales so whether
you're selling a product whether you're
selling a service whether you're selling
an idea whether you're selling yourself
if you want to be in the top 0.1% You'
got to get good at articulating
communicating and sales number three is
super successful people never try and do
it alone they don't do it alone they get
in groups they find networks mentors
they get around support groups I looked
at Arnold Schwarz snigger I recently
watched the Netflix movie or documentary
Arnold and it was interesting to see how
he was desperately wanting to get to
America because he felt like the
environment and his support network
would be better in America he joined a
gym and was around other people doing
the same thing and then he became
Champion Mr Olympia he became a
millionaire in real estate but if you
look at his whole journey he was around
people if you're trying to be successful
alone you're never going to be
successful the reason I became
successful was because I got in support
networks around other people because
ultimately you are who you hang around
and if you're just on your own at home
trying to be successful with with a
skeptical mom and dad or a moody partner
it's never ever ever going to happen
you've got to break into new
environments if you're an eagle but
you're in a chicken Coupe your whole
mindset is just going to be like a
chicken and you're never going to fly
you've got to get around the Eagles if
you want to be successful Point number
four is you have to invest all of your
profits all of your money back into your
business I mean I make a lot of money do
you know what I do with most of the
money I reinvest it back into my
business back into my brand this is the
growth mindset that the top 0.1% have
that the middle class the poor the
working class and even the comfortable
you know I even see some millionaires
Grant Cardone talks about this where he
says never listen to a millionaire
because most of them are dead beats they
make a you know a million pounds or they
realiz the net worth a million they're
in their 50s and then they become super
risk averse and hold on to what they've
got like this they become a pond whereas
the top 0.1% the super rich are not
ponds they are reservoirs they're rivers
and money flows through them and they
invest what they make back into building
their business I see this with all rich
people look at Elon Musk I mean Elon
Musk just invested 43 billion pounds
into buying Twitter and then change The
Branding you know it's just crazy
Madness and if you look at all
billionaires they always growing their
business if they've had a good year and
they've made a bit of money they're
going to then employ new people right so
they're thinking about growth they're
thinking about in increasing their
turnover and their revenues and their
sales investing back into their brand
investing back into their education
that's what the 0.01% of people always
always always do Point number five is
that they invest in assets that cannot
be taken away from them that produce
cash flow and capital appreciation
whether you're in the business of you
know you're in the car business I know a
guy called Lord Bob edminston who's a
billionaire he's in the car business
he's making crazy money he owns the uh
the Subaru car across across Europe but
what does he do with his profits from
the car business he puts it into real
estate he has a massive property
business in fact now he makes more money
from the property business than he does
the he does the car business and you can
see this if you go on the Sunday Times
rich list and you look at all the rich
people I mean some of them made money in
property but those that made money in
business they then invest into property
or maybe not even property other assets
gold silver index funds rich people
invest their money into things that
cannot be taken away from them I
personally think that property is the
best thing is very difficult to get
taken away if you own land it's very
difficult to take that ever off you even
if you burn the house down you still got
the land so you want assets and the rich
people own assets that not only hold
their value but also produce cash flow
as well so that's Point number five
point number six the top 0.1% of wealthy
people that make masses amount of money
they understand that to protect their
profits from being taxed on paper they
need to not make any profits this is why
some of the biggest companies in the
world like uber Uber apparently don't
make any profit hm how is it that Uber
don't make any profit
how how is it that they drain their
profits from their company why would
they still be running because they do
that deliberately so that they don't
have to pay taxes in very clever ways
look at Nike Nike have an offshore
account that owns the trading Mark to
Nike which charges the Western companies
that own Nike as a way of putting money
into a tax country that doesn't pay tax
to avoid paying taxes legally you can't
necessarily set up a structure like that
unless you're an international company
and a big firm but what you can do is
you can think well hang on if this year
I've done a million p and my profit is
800 Grand I don't want to pay profit on
800 Grand how can I start how can I get
t-shirts that are tax deductible with my
name on it how can IOP my phone this is
not my phone this is my company phone
how can I shrink my profits maybe I need
to going back to growing and reinvesting
into yourself maybe I need to hire more
staff so that I can bring down my profit
on paper so that I can grow bigger as a
company and at the same time reduce my
tax massively so this is something that
I didn't understand this at all I
remember getting hit in my 20s with a
1.6 million tax bill and it people
killed this way aren't putting aside
money for tax so the top
0.1% understand that to protect their
profits from tax they need to have as
little profit as they can on paper Point
number seven is the top 0.1% don't care
about being liked they have no interest
in being liked I've noticed actually
that normal people they all want to be
liked they won't say something that's
going to make them dislikes worried
about what people think of them Steve
Jobs didn't care what people thought of
him Elon Musk doesn't give a rip if he's
liked or not you know the amount of hate
that he gets online do you think he
reads it and cares and lose sleep over
it he don't give him monkeys rich people
don't care Bill Gates people paint Bill
Gates out to be an absolute demon do you
think he cares you think he loses sleep
over it of course he doesn't the guy's a
multi-billionaire the top 0.1% of people
do not care at all about being liked or
not they do care about their reputation
they'll protect their reputation with
their life they'll protect their brands
you know people are saying lies that
aren't true I mean I've had to do this
I've had people saying lies about me
that aren't true n man you don't put the
facts on the table people will make
stuff up so you got to protect your
brand but you can't care and take it
personal if you are not liked and that's
rich people absolutely don't number
eight is they're never satisfied and
enough is Never Enough they're always
pushing to the next level you never see
a billionaire that just goes you know
what
I think I might retire now the top
0.1% are all they're goal driven there's
always another Mountaintop High they're
pushing to get to and I think the reason
for that is a lot of people think that
when they become a millionaire they'll
relax cool off go live on a beach
somewhere and not work but actually that
creates misery and depression real
fulfillment and happiness happens in
progression when you're pushing towards
a goal when you can see the Mountaintop
that makes you hope for and filled with
hope and joy when you get to the top of
the mountain then we going to climb back
down it's the reason why a lot of
astronauts are suicidal because they
come back down from from from space and
then it's like well what now we did it
we've arrived so the top 0.1% they hit
their goal but they're always pushing
the next thing the next thing the next
thing and often the goal has to be
bigger than you it's not just about
making money it becomes about leaving a
legacy a purpose having a massive
massive goal that's going to keep you
going until after you've died point nine
is they always have mentors and coaches
to hold them to account because the top
0.1% of people are smart they understand
why would you reinvent the wheel when
someone's done something before if
someone's done something before why am I
going to go well no no no let me figure
out the route all by myself I'm not
going to use a satin have I'm not going
to read a map I'm just going to figure
it out as I go because it's nonsense
it's dumb it will take you forever to
get there you better have to find
someone who's been the way that you want
to go how did you get there study what
they did and that's what I did I studied
what rich people have done how they
think how they are how their business
Works found out what they know and then
I became rich and all rich and
successful people have had mentors even
if their mentors have been maybe they've
had a father in their life who's who
who's successful in business and they've
copied their their father have had an
unofficial Mentor I've never met a
billionaire who's got to where they've
got to without people helping them
coaching them Consulting them along the
way which brings me finally to point 10
by the way I hope you enjoying the video
and finally the 10th thing that all rich
people do and to be in the top 0.1% of
people you got to start doing this way
more and that is rich people take risks
they're not so risk averse they don't
wait for all the traffic lights to be on
green before they just go they'll take
risks they'll be bold they'll be
courageous Elon Musk investing 43
billion on Twitter that's a risk it's
still in the days what's going to happen
like taking big risks I saw an
interesting quote actually I'm going to
read this to you which says this
billionaires risk Millions to become
billionaires millionaires risk thousands
or hundreds of thousands to become
millionaires broke people typically want
to lose nothing yet still become rich
this is the broken mindset of poor
people not wanting to risk anything an
example would be this I run a crash
course property investors crash course
where I personally run it for a whole
day and condense everything on about
property investment and making money in
property in in into one day and the
course is1 pound pound it's it's
ridiculous it's it's a complete loss
leader to me sometimes people will say
oh but it's an hour away and I'm not
sure it's a bit they're scared to pay 20
in Petro or catch a bus or whatever
because they think oh what happens if it
doesn't work what happens if I come all
the way down book a hotel pay a pound
and it's like man if you're not prepared
to risk losing one day out your life and
and a bit of bus faral pet money for
potentially a completely change of your
financial life forever then you don't
really deserve to be successful anyway
rich people will say what if what could
happen not well what could go wrong what
if it doesn't work it's what if it does
work so with that being said you know
what I'm going to leave a link in the
description there's probably going to be
I don't know how many but at least three
four 5 thousand people that will be
likely to watch this video out of the
thousands of people that will watch the
video how many people would actually go
you know what I'm going to invest one
and I'm going to put a day aside
probably only 100 maybe probably maybe
only 1% will you be the top 1% let's
find out